hey guys the last time I didn't have
anywhere near enough energy so I'm damn
sure I'm gonna make up for it this time
so work what you're looking at is an
animation which I produced at the
earth's temperature evolving over time
the rest of the slightly hotter the blue
stuff slightly colder the really blue
bits are the Himalayas the Andes and the
Vinson Massif in Antarctica the reason
they're really blue is because we don't
have any beta there because there's sort
of land in the way of this particular
height what I'm currently doing is
working on my own model at the
atmosphere and producing an animation
like this of my model and see how it
compares to the actual data which as you
can see is really really complicated
it's really beautiful I can watch it
ours mean that was only six months of
data that you saw and there's 40 years
of it so my version is gonna be nowhere
near as complicated and it's probably
look like an 8-bit version of the
atmosphere but hopefully next week I'll
be able to show you my model of the
Earth's climate and it's gonna be
terrible by comparison but that's
science for you you know but hopefully
by the end of this term we'll get that
Jamie you asked me what I'd be doing
with my life if I hadn't gone off from
Oxford
well my reserve choice the universe of
universities was Leeds doing physics at
Lee's which I would have gone to if I
didn't get my three days or get from
Oxford and if I hadn't well I always
knew when I was in sixth form that I
wanted to Karen with education I wasn't
done with learning so I think if I
hadn't got any offers from universities
at all I would have apply again and
again and again but if that failed then
probably gone something done something
to do with writing journalism I guess I
feel like our questions have been very
serious so maybe this week we should try
something a little bit different what's
your favorite video game of all time and
I know that you like video games so I
expect an in detail dance it's give it
like a 15 minute video probably but yeah
it like in five minutes or less what's
your favorite video game
social instant pieces we had this
amazing perk called
Anna McCrory she's actually the
president though she used to be the
president the Oxford Poetry Society
and she's going to get him a fringe to
do a set of poetry and she wants to test
it out on a buncha guinea pigs basically
which I happen to be one of she did his
show on Monday testing this set outputs
and Peter's beings and Peter's there
were loads of great
people that wants to be involved so we
had an evening of music spoken word and
poetry and they ranged from a poem about
Brian Cox a light poem she doesn't do
love poems and I'm gonna give you this
clip of her which is her political
opinions that before don't be Foreign
Affairs they muddled me scandalous and
puzzled me that he you visibles me no I
don't know much about politics I want to
get one of her other fair poems on my
channel in full so that's hopefully sent
to look forward to in the very near
future also yesterday my parents came up
to visit me which is great because it
means I get free lunch but I also get to
see my parents my mom also bought a home
on a coke Punk your mum my mum seen here
next to the death mask of Oliver
Cromwell suggested the ghost Ashmolean
Museum which kind of suggests why she's
next to the death mask of Oliver
Cromwell so the Ashmolean museum or to
give its full name the Ashmolean museum
of art and archaeology is the world's
oldest university museum is actually the
first public museum in the UK it was
founded in 1677 based on the cabinet of
curiosities that Elias a tional this
dude in the picture gave the University
if he into your art then it has
contributions from Michelangelo Monet
MANET Gainsborough Lazaro Titian van
Gogh Vega Renoir Turner and there is a
DaVinci somewhere but I can find it on
the archaeological side of things
there's absolutely loads of stuff which
we didn't get around to this time but
they had amongst other things this sword
it's incredibly ugly baby
this derby line and the world's most
uncomfortable looking pair of underwear
if you're ever in Oxford just do go and
check it out it's one of most amazing
museums I've been here for four years
and I still haven't managed to make the
most of it
my question to you the viewer so by now
we're halfway through this blogging
project I've been vlogging you all of
last time we're halfway through this
time I'd like to know from you guys what
you'd like to see me do you more up John
me to see more of Oxford doing to have
me talk more about my work maybe explain
some more my work to you if you have any
ideas any suggestions about what you'd
like this series to become in the future
I'm literally open to everything please
leave your suggestions in the comments
also if you haven't yet posted your
stories and myths which you've heard
about Oxford please do leave them in the
comment section I'm going to be sitting
down sometime next week with an
officially college type person to go
through all these stories that you've
heard and determine whether they are
true or not and try and shed some light
on the subject I think that's it for me
this week have a fantastic week
everybody if you like the video feel
free to like it you don't have to if you
don't want to and yeah I will see you on
Thursday Jamie
nerdfighters I hope you're happy